Amelia is a six-year-old girl who just
like any kid wants to play and have fun
however her mother doesn't want her to
waste time on those things Amelia is
often forced to participate in beauty
pageants and other fashion shows the
selfish mom mentions that if she has to
choose between her daughter's
intelligence and her beauty she will
always pick the latter the little girl
also starts believing that her mom is
right so she makes it her dream to
become a fashion model several years
passed by and Amelia has fulfilled her
dream like such as she has become a top
supermodel with the world at her feet
hundreds and thousands of eager fans
flock to her shows to catch a glimpse of
her however despite the lavish nature of
her profession Emilia also feels bored
and lonely this is because of the
Annoying Paparazzi that always surrounds
her the friends who only care about her
status and the rich people who simply
treat her as a commodity so one day when
she meets a caring and handsome guy
named Harry she immediately falls in
love with him Harry is a real estate
businessman has amassed millions over
the course of his career but despite his
richness he is a passionate lover who
treats Emilia like a princess and always
makes her feel wanted their romantic
fling soon turns into a serious
relationship and Emilia moves into the
Millionaire's lavish house for the first
few weeks everything goes well and
Amelia lives some of the happiest
moments of her life she sometimes
wonders if she is in a fairy tale with
everything perfect around her however
one morning the fairy tale world around
her suddenly begins to crumble Emilia
wakes up to a loud noise and when she
heads to Harry's room she finds him
assembling a large shelf on the wall
confused Amelia inquires what's going on
and Harry replies that he's making this
shelf for her thinking that it's for her
large collection of shoes Amelia happily
thanks him but Harry reveals that it's
not for the shoes it's for her he wants
Amelia to sit on the Shelf all the time
so that he can stare at her and get
motivation Harry mentions that he
doesn't want to take his eyes off of
something so beautiful moreover he
believes that this will boost his work
rate as well hearing all this Amelia is
a bit weirded out and she hesitates to
comply since she is a supermodel she has
to travel the world and give important
interviews all the time however Harry
explains that an extraordinary girl like
her doesn't have to live an ordinary
life she should just quit her job and
stay with him In This Very Room gazing
at him from the Shelf Harry promises to
take care of her in the best way
possible buying her expensive dresses
and feeding her delicious meals he also
vows to worship her every day before
going to work Amelia is still a bit
skeptical about the idea I mean the
trophy wife metaphor is just too on the
nose but when Harry mentions that it
would mean the world to him she finally
accepts well following this Harry helps
her onto the shelf and gazes at her for
a while he says that this is a life
which many people can only dream of
after he leaves to prepare Breakfast
Amelia who is now at the top of the
Shelf starts pondering if she made the
right choice some days later the couple
finally decides to get married however
even on this special day Amelia sits
Atop The Shelf she is clad in a lovely
outfit and hundreds of wealthy people
stare at her beauty and awe after the
celebrations are over Harry climbs onto
the shelf and the two make passionate
love shelf sex damn this signals the
start of their rather confusing
relationship as the days pass Amelia
tries her best to keep herself busy on
the Shelf she reads magazines puts on
makeup and even performs basic exercises
she makes very loud noises while
exercising which disrupts Henry's calls
with his clients however rather than
being angry he maintains his creepy
smile and says that the business calls
are actually disturbing him from seeing
his beautiful wife Henry further Pampers
Amelia by continuing to bring her
bouquets of flowers expensive jewelry
and chocolates it appears as if the
lovebirds are going to set the Benchmark
for the happiest couple ever but soon
things start deteriorating Henry gets
bored of his wife so he starts giving
her less attention by the day he no
longer brings her gifts and gets annoyed
when she makes the exercise noises Henry
doesn't even want to chat with her
anymore and ignores her all the time
because of this Emilia has become a mere
decoration in his room her dreams of
living a fairy tale life have all but
ended with Henry now cold and distant to
her Amelia often tries initiating
conversations with the housekeeper but
even the latter is ordered to not
respond more than hello and how are you
my shelf in a desperate attempt to make
things right one day Amelia puts on her
best outfit hoping she can entice her
husband back however to her dismay Henry
doesn't even bat an eye towards her
instead he complains about not getting
enough sunlight so he shifts his desk to
another side now Amelia can't even see
her husband's face and for the first
time she breaks down in desperation
following this the movie Fast forwards
by three years Emilia still sits Atop
The Shelf she has become a prisoner in
her own house at this point she hasn't
even seen her husband in months as Harry
never ventures in inside this room
anymore Amelia hopes and prays that he
will change his attitude and treat her
like a princess once again but he slowly
goes away from her life so one day fed
up with her situation Amelia finally
decides to get off the shelf however it
is not an easy task as after all these
years of living on the Shelf both her
physical and mental states are weak when
Amelia looks down she sees that the
height between her and the ground is a
lot but in reality it is only a few feet
despite this she is determined to get
down and end her nightmare once and for
all At first she drops one of her shoes
to check how long it takes to strike the
ground however her brain once again
gives her false calculations terrifying
her Amelia then drops her second shoe
but the result is no different the risk
far outweighs the reward but she doesn't
want to rot in this state forever so
Amelia decides to give it a shot she
slowly climbs down the shelf and at one
point she even clings onto one of the
ledges precariously however when she
cannot hold it any longer she falls in
Amelia's perspective it is a frightening
fall from thousands of meters but when
she hits the ground she is left unharmed
in this way Amelia has finally touched
the ground after years of being on the
Shelf she somehow manages to get on her
feet as her atrophied legs are not used
to walking then she heads out and feels
the Cool Breeze making her Overjoyed in
the next scene Amelia does all sorts of
things that a child would do she dips
her legs into the swimming pool throws a
bunch of tennis balls on the ground and
dances her way throughout the house she
was a full-grown adult when she was
kidnapped of course but she was a model
let's give her a pass after this she
puts on her shoes and hitches a ride on
a mail truck when Amelia reaches the
city she is flabbergasted to witness the
fast-moving Society all these years of
confinement have taken a toll on her
mindset but now she is a bird Unleashed
Amelia dances around the busy streets
delighted that she is part of the
society once again she hugs the mail
truck which brought her here talks to
strangers and even rides around the city
in a random man's scooter alright theft
soon Amelia goes to jail
soon Amelia reaches the beach area where
she continues her childish Antics she
dances with strangers stares off a man's
parking ticket chases a dog and
interrupts a yoga class after this she
makes her way to the beach which used to
be her favorite place before she became
a trophy on the wall there seeing her
dance some random people suddenly join
her Bollywood style and have a fun time
then Amelia jumps into the sea and
starts swimming like a fish 10 minutes
ago her muscles were atrophied but no
longer she is having the best time of
her life with no sense of worry in her
mind however reality soon comes crashing
to her in the form of a huge wave as
Emilia gets out of the sea totally
soaked in water she begins shivering
with cold she heads over to a couple of
strangers to ask for a towel but this
time they are not in the mood to
entertain her don't you know that Tick
Tock blew our attention span sweetheart
your last minutes
dejected Emilia wanders around the town
until she comes across a makeup store
inside she notices some women getting
pretty makeovers and compares it with
her face which is totally messed up due
to dirt and washed up mascara Emilia
feels terrible for her state so she
Ventures inside the shop and uses the
free samples to clean her face in a
matter of minutes she returns to her
pretty self making her feel confident as
Emilia prepares to leave one of the
store clerks Jordan approaches her and
curiously asks if she is a makeup artist
Jordan is astounded as to how she was
able to put on such lovely makeup so
quickly however Amelia reveals that she
is actually a wall trophy whose only job
is to please a rich millionaire Jordan
is slightly surprised by the strange
profession but she doesn't judge Amelia
for it instead she mentions that if one
is happy with their job no matter how
menial or small it is life will always
be good Amelia responds by echoing her
late mother's words who always
prioritized Beauty over intelligence
however Jordan corrects her by saying
that she can be both at the same time
hearing this Amelia's perspective of the
world changes in an instant the first
thing she does is head home and destroy
Roy the shelf that kept her hostage for
all these years now she is free not only
physically but also psychologically the
movie then skips to one year in the
future Emilia using both her beauty and
intelligence has opened her own makeup
store which she is named Amelia it is a
huge success and hundreds of people line
up on the streets to catch a glimpse of
her exemplary products inside the store
surprisingly Amelia is once again seen
sitting on a shelf above her is a neon
lit sign which reads let everyone look
Amelia wants everyone to notice her
beauty and intelligence with the help of
which she has become a successful
businesswoman she is proud that she has
finally achieved something commendable
in her life however when the clients
come into her store they don't engage in
conversation they simply say hi or hello
just like her former housekeeper did
nice shelf subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching